[Music]
now Beyonce's never-before-seen family
album I was with the queen bee at Super
Bowl 50 in the Bay Area 16 months before
twins Rumi and sir were born today
Beyonce released new pics from the two
stadiums where she performed in half
time showing Blue Ivy got all the
attention behind the scenes
check out the then pouty four year old
posing with mom on the field she was
also a rascal with dad stealing the ball
formation I mean people are going crazy
about this video the making of mrs.
Carter's most recent momentous halftime
performance is detailed in a new coffee
table book part of her how to make
lemonade box set at more than 600 pages
it also sheds light on her painstaking
journey to complete the visual album
lemonade from her costume mock-up for
freedom to this concept collage for sari
even handwritten lyrics are included
from the album which seemed to reference
marital strife with jay-z
[Music]
but it's all good now and the Carters
have plenty of room to spread out a
source confirmed CET that jay-z and
Beyonce just closed on this 30,000
square foot Bel Air mansion purchase
price 90 million
[Music]
you